-My next guest has
one of the biggest social media
followings in the world.
She's also the host of "A Little
Late with Lilly Singh."
Season 2 premiered last night
and airs weeknights
at 1:35 a.m. on NBC.
Set your DVRs.
Here's our pal Lilly Singh.
Oh!
-Hey, Jimmy, my man!
So good to see you.
-Look at you.
You look fantastic.
Thank you so much for doing this
and being here.
-I know, I bring
all the Tinky-Winky vibes.
-You do? [ Laughs ]
Is that Tinky-Winky?
I love that.
-Boop.
-Dude, last time
you were on the show --
By the way, congrats
on the show, Season 2.
Watched last night.
-Thank you.
-Loved your Kamala Harris.
-And you had
a good little inside joke
about being on at 1:35.
I loved it.
But the -- I was thinking,
I go, didn't --
'Cause I remember --
Somehow I connected you two
for some reason. I go,
"Why did I connect this?"
And you met President -- Vice
President-Elect Kamala Harris
on our show,
the last time you did our show.
-Yes, I did.
And you don't understand
it's the biggest flex --
There it is.
It's the biggest flex ever.
I vividly remember.
I think this was actually
the day that was before
my Season 1 premiere.
-Yes.
-Where, you know,
Kamala Harris was
the first guest, and she came,
and they said, "Hey, Kamala
Harris would like to say hi."
And I was like,
"Uh, yes, absolutely."
And she proceeded
to just be amazing.
She was like, "Lilly,
everything you're doing,
I love that you're doing it,
and it's so important.
And you're a big voice
for the community."
And she was saying
all these things
about how I'm so inspiring
and I'm paving a path.
And I'm like,
you're Kamala Harris.
Like, how are you
saying this to me?
-You're that. You're that.
-I'm like, "Am I
in the Matrix right now?
Like, this is you.
You are that person."
-Who is talking about who? Yeah.
That's so funny.
-You know that meme of
Spider-Man looking at himself?
-Yes, of course.
Dude, Spider-Man.
-Literally, I was like,
"I am shook
that you're saying this about me
because --" And I have to say
that her energy and presence
was just so invigorating.
I think I went out and did
my most comfortable performance
with you, Jimmy,
'cause I was Kamalafied.
She Kamalafied me.
-Kamalafied.
You became Kamalafied.
And so you just came out
and just --
Yeah, you did rip it up
that night. It was great.
-Thank you.
-I wanted to ask you
about what you --
'Cause quarantine, everyone's at
home and trying to be safe.
But I think -- I did.
A lot of people did --
Took to social media
to just start doing things.
And you, who I first
were introduced to you
because you were
a YouTube superstar,
uh, and I was going to ask you,
what did you think of all of it,
and what did you think
of everyone's stuff?
-Yeah. I mean, you know,
like most people,
quarantine for me has been
a time of reflecting.
It took a global pandemic
for me to sit and be like,
"What is my life?
What do I like?
What are my priorities?"
Um, and, you know,
I think I'm a big believer
that everything
is a double-edged sword. Right?
I love social media.
I have a career
because of social media.
I'm sitting here with you right
now because of social media.
And so I do think
it's a wonderful tool
to connect people,
to get informed,
to feel part of something.
But, you know, I'd be remiss
if I didn't say
that it also can be quite toxic.
And I think I got into
a little bit of a phase
where I thought
Twitter was real life
and Instagram was real life.
And I was living in that world.
And then I had to be like, "This
is not how I want to live."
Like, there is so much
toxicity online.
Um, and I talked about this
in the season --
in the premiere monologue,
that especially during
the Black Lives Matter movement,
I felt like social media
was just so full of division.
And I actually went to a protest
in real life,
and it was beautiful.
And for me, that was that moment
where I thought,
"The real world
deserves our attention,
as much or more than
I'm giving it on the phone."
And so I deleted social media
off my phone during quarantine.
And it's been really great.
I feel like
I'm a lot more present.
-Really?
-Apparently,
there's trees outside.
-No, no, that's not true.
-Don't know when that happened.
-There's trees in my backyard.
I was like,
"When did these get here?"
-Wait, dude,
trees are trending right now.
Trees are trending #2,
people rediscovering trees.
They love it.
-Yeah, literally.
-Yeah. That's so --
Wait, so you just
went no Twitter?
-Yeah, I mean,
I deleted it off my phone.
I won't lie. It's kind of like
a drunk relationship.
Like you know how when people
get drunk, they text their ex?
My thing is if I get drunk,
I download Twitter.
Like, this is my relationship
with Twitter.
I be drunk and I'm like,
"You know, just one tweet,
one quick -- It means nothing."
And then I download Twitter.
So I definitely relapse
and have moments.
But I try to not -- You know
what I'm trying to avoid, Jimmy?
I'm trying to avoid
the human tendency we have,
where if we have a spare
four minutes before anything,
we go like this.
-Yes.
-I'm trying to get rid of that.
-Yeah.
-Because I'd rather do this.
I'd rather be, like,
checking in with myself.
I'd rather control the energy
I'm getting in my day.
And I just don't want
to give that control away.
-Yeah, I find that, I go,
"Oh, that is so annoying
if somebody does that."
And then once someone does it,
it makes me want
to look at my phone.
-Exactly. Exactly.
-What am I missing out on?
You know, and it's like --
-Because you
feel like the idiot.
You're like, "Oh,
should I be doing this, too?"
-Yeah. We have to find out
what's new, who's trending,
who hates who, what's going on.
It's like, "No, I --"
-And I find myself magnetically
attracted to comments and drama.
And that's on me.
I feel like I go onto anything,
I'm diving in the comments.
-It's human.
-"Oh, someone wrote something?
What did people reply saying?"
And now I'm in this world
where I'm like,
"How did I get here?
Why do I care
about any of this?"
-Yeah, no,
it's just a human thing.
I wanted to ask you
about Season 2.
You changed it up. It's great.
-Thanks!
-I love that you did that.
I think it's good.
You have to try --
Everyone should try new things
and see what sticks.
And it's like,
you totally changed it
from the first season.
-I did. I grabbed it
by the reins, to be honest.
You know, Season 1, for me --
I'll just be honest.
I came on your show,
Jimmy, Season 1.
I was wearing that green outfit,
and I came, and I said,
"I'm breaking the rules
of late night.
You know, I'm going
to change the format."
And then I literally proceeded
to do the exact same format
and did everything that I said
I'm wasn't going to do.
And I take that "L"
on my shoulders
because I think Season 1, I was
learning a complete new world.
You know? The learning curve
was so steep for me.
And so, I found myself
not being completely myself.
I found myself
trying to be someone
that would please
the late-night world
and please all the articles
and headlines.
And so I had to, like,
really have a talk with myself
before Season 2 and say,
"You need to make this you."
And that's what I've done.
-Since you started the new
season, started last night,
but everyone should watch.
After me, after Seth,
comes Lilly.
Uh, and so, 1:35, check it out.
I want to ask you maybe
some new questions about you.
-Sure.
-Ready?
Alright. What is your new jam?
What's a new song
that you discovered?
-Hmm, okay, well,
Saweetie was my first guest,
and I discovered her song
"Best Friend" with Doja Cat.
And I can't twerk, but that song
makes me want to try.
You know? It really makes me
want to try to twerk,
and I love it.
-What's a new game
that you've played?
-Okay, so, I think
I'm late to the party here,
'cause I think people
have been on this for a while,
but during the pandemic,
I discovered Catan.
And now I am
a full-fledged nerd.
And I play online and in-person,
and I am just --
Catan is my thing.
-Dude, I want to make a T-shirt
that says,
"Nobody wants your sheep."
-Yeah -- Exact-- That's ge--
Send me one. That's genius.
-Nobody wants your sheep.
[ Both laugh ]
-Wow. I've never felt more seen.
-Wow. That is a nerdy thing
that just happened.
Alright, I love that.
-Hey, Jimmy, Jimmy,
that settles it.
-Dude, that settles it.
And by the way,
"a little late to the party,"
that's a segment
on your show right there.
-Alright, we're gonna
offline this.
-"A little late to the party."
That's what you're doing.
That's a new segment.
Alright. Here we go.
What's your newest mantra?
-My newest mantra
is quite simple.
It is simply, "What kind of life
do you want to live?"
And I know
that sounds very basic.
But the reason
it's been working for me
is I feel like I identified
so many reasons I used to
get flustered in life
was I'd be
giving away control --
people online, to producers,
to all this stuff.
And when you ask yourself,
"What kind of life
do you want to live?"
it kind of helps you
frame the situation
where you can take control.
Do you want the life where you
have to listen to these people
and you have to be
near these people
and you have to feel this way?
Or do you want the life where
you can do something about it
and remove yourself
from those situations
or, like, you know,
take a different path?
And so, "What kind of life
do you want to live?"
is a big thing for me.
-I love that.
There's a new episode of your
show airing tonight on NBC.
Who's on the show tonight?
-Brie Larson! Brie Larson's
on the show, which is --
I know. I'm like,
"These famouses have taken time
to talk to me? I'm shook."
-I love Brie Larson.
-But it's super cool.
She sings and plays me
some of my comments musically.
So it's super fun.
-No way.
-Yeah, I also teach you
how to make a drink.
A Solo Sex on the Beach,
I teach in my episode today.
Um, and I just want to make it
clear, I'm not a mixologist,
but I do have
a strong will to drink.
And I believe
it's the same thing.
-Congrats on the new season.
And you still have
the best fashion,
best kicks in the game, man.
Oh, my God.
Your sneakers, come on.
Always, always something cool.
New season of
"A Little Late with Lilly Singh"
airs weeknights at 1:35 on NBC.
Watch it tonight.